>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU,
JOHN SOLOMON, GRADE REPORTING.
IF IT WERE AFTER THE SO-CALLED
JOURNALISTS -- THERE ARE NONE OF
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA -- NONE OF
US WOULD EVER GET REPORTED.
BIDEN WOULD NEVER BE FULLY
VETTED.
AS LYCAN 2008 WITH
BARACK OBAMA.
REMEMBER, THEIR SHOW
INVESTIGATED OBAMA'S TIES TO
YOU, YEAH, UNREPENTANT DOMESTIC
TERRORIST, BERNADINE DORN, BILL
AYRES.
IT WAS ALSO ON THIS SHOW THAT
WERE DIGGING INTO HIS DEEP
PERSONAL CONNECTION TO REVEREND
WRIGHT, THE CHURCH OF GD
AMERICA.
AND BLACK LIBERATION THEOLOGY,
THAT SO INSPIRED HIM AND ACORN
AND COMMUNITY ORGANIZING AND
EVEN AND EVEN THE GANG AND SO
MUCH MORE.
REMEMBER THROUGHOUT HIS
PRESIDENCY, IT WAS REALLY UP TO
US TO COVER PAY SCANDAL-PLAGUED
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE, WELL,
JOURNALISM IS DEAD AND IT'S
BEEN VERY QUITE A WHILE,
UNFORTUNATELY.
MOST OF THE MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
ARE NOTHING MORE THAN CHILLS AND
AN EXTENSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT YOU, WE
COME OF THE PEOPLE.
THINGS HAVE IMPROVED SO MUCH
UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND THEY HATE
HIM.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY BE CHAMPIONING
SUCCESS FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST?
INTERESTING QUESTION.
THIS WAS PERFECTLY EXEMPLIFIED
DURING THE PRESIDENT'S RECENT
TRIPS TO SOUTH KOREA.
PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION.
ALL RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT GOES TO
THE DMZ.
PRESIDENT TRUMP QUICKLY COME
AFTER ME TO EAT OUT
YOUR NORTH KOREAN KIM JONG UN.
BECAME THE FIRST SITTING U.S.
PRESIDENT TO CROSS THE DMZ.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, LET'S SEE, HE
OFFERED NO CONCESSIONS TO
NORTH KOREA, THE SANCTIONS ARE
STILL VERY MUCH IN PLACE.
IN OTHER WORDS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID NOT TRY TO BRIBE THE
NORTH KOREAN REGIME LIKE
BILL CLINTON DID WITH YOUR MONEY
IN THE MID-'90s AND TELL US,
THIS IS A GOOD DEAL FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NOR DID PRESIDENT TRUMP DROP
$150 BILLION IN CASH AND OTHER
CURRENCY ON A TARMAC TO MULLAHS
IN IRAN, LIKE BIDEN AND OBAMA
DID DURING THEIR FAILED IRANIAN
NUCLEAR DEAL.
NO, THIS PRESIDENT WON'T TRY TO
APPEASE, BRIBE DICTATORS, BUT HE
ALSO HATES UNNECESSARY WARS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT AN
INTERVENTIONIST.
HE IS ABOUT AMERICA.
HIS POLICY IS CLEAR.
AMERICA FIRST, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FIRST.
HIS FOREIGN POLICY AND DIPLOMACY
SURROUNDS ECONOMIC PRESSURE.
OPEN LINES OF COMMUNICATION.
WE SEE THAT WITH IRAN.
IRAN IS DESPERATE BECAUSE OF THE
MEASURES AND OF COURSE THE
SANCTIONS THE PRESIDENT HAS PUT
ON IRAN.
HE'S TAPPING AND NOW TO
AMERICAN'S VAST OIL AND NATURAL
GAS
RESERVES.
THAT MEANS THE STRAITS OF HORMUZ
AREN'T LESS STRATEGICALLY
IMPORTANT THAN EVER BEFORE.
BY THE WAY, YOU WANT TO SEE THE
WEALTH OF THE AVERAGE MAN AND
WOMAN IN THIS COUNTRY RISE?
S BE NOT ONLY ENERGY
INDEPENDENT, BUT LET'S SHARE
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE REST
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESH
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESE
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESW
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESR
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESD
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESO
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESU
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESW
OUR VAST RESOURCES WITH THE RESL
SEE THE STANDARD OF LIVING OF
EVERY AMERICAN GO THROUGH THE
ROOF.
WHY WOULDN'T THE NEWS MEDIA WANT
TO TELL YOU THAT?
AND BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT
VIEWS MILITARY ACTION AS A LAST
RESULTS.
THE ONLY THING HE USES IS
OFFERED TO KIM JONG UN, IRAN,
AND PUTIN -- DROPPED MY PEN --
IS HIS TIME, HIS ATTENTION, HE
SUFFERED NOTHING MORE.
AND THAT IS NOT WHAT GETS
REPORTED.
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA CAN'T SEE
THROUGH THEIR RAGE, THEIR
PSYCHOSIS, TO TRULY UNDERSTAND
THIS PRESIDENT.
SO NATURALLY THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, THEY WERE OUTRAGED.
THE PRESIDENT CURED CANCER,
THEY'D BE OUTRAGED.
ALL BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT HAD
THE AUDACITY TO SIMPLY HOLD A
MEETING.
REMEMBER, HE GOT HOSTAGES BACK,
HE GOT REMAINS BACK.
AND HE EVEN GOT THE ROCKETS FROM
NOT BEING FIRED EVERY OTHER DAY.
HE'S GIVEN NOTHING BUT TIME!
THAT'S IT.
NOTHING ELSE.
UNLIKE CLINTON, BIDEN, AND
OBAMA.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT MAKES ME WANT TO PUKE, MY
VISCERAL REACTION IS AN AMERICAN
WHO CARES ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS.
THE FACT THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
GOING OUT OF HIS WAY TO KISS UP
TO THIS MONSTER.
>> HE SAID SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WE SHOULD NOT LET GO BY, "THIS
IS AN HONOR TO BE HERE WITH YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IT IS NOT AN
HONOR TO BE THERE WITH A BRUTAL,
MURDEROUS DICTATOR.
THE UNITED STATES PRESIDENT
MEETING WITH THE LEADER OF
NORTH KOREA WAS REGARDED AS A
RIGHT THAT NO ADMINISTRATION HAD
GRANTED.
UNITED STATES PRESIDENT VISITING
NORTH KOREA WAS REGARDED AS A
GREAT PRIZE THAT WAS GIVEN AWAY
FOR PRETTY MUCH NOTHING.
>> THIS IS THE DRAMATIC
HEADLINE, THE DRAMATIC PHOTO,
HE'S A GREAT SHOWMAN, HE PULLED
IT OFF.
TODAY THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT.
>> IT IS HARD TO ANTICIPATE
ANYTHING MORE THAN THIS BEING A
PHOTO OP THAT LEADS TO MORE TALK
THAT MAY NOT LEAD TO ANYTHING.
>> Sean: OH, BY NOT LEAD TO
ANYTHING.
MAYBE IT MIGHT LEAD TO SOMETHING
LIKE MORE REMAINS BEING SENT TO
SOMETHING, MORE HOSTAGES FREED.
WHO KNOWS WHERE IT WILL LEAD.
THAT WAS JUST ONE OF MANY MEDIA
MELTDOWNS IN RECENT DAYS.
THERE IS NOTHING THIS PRESIDENT
CAN DO THAT WILL SATISFY THEM.
OTHERS SURROUNDING THE
PRESIDENT'S BRIEF MEETING WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN OF THE G20
SUMMIT, WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
HILARIOUS.
THE PRESS DID NOT THINK HE WAS
STRONG ENOUGH ON HIS MORNING
AGAINST RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
THEY SAID TO HIM, ARE YOU GOING
TO TELL THEM TO STOP MEDDLING IN
THE ELECTIONS?
YEARS OF THE PRESIDENT SAID.
>> I THINK PUTIN, FOR HIS PART,
FEELS AS THOUGH THAT ATTITUDE,
THE CAVALIER ATTITUDE ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN THREAT TO OUR
FUNDAMENTAL SYSTEM, GIVES THEM
LICENSE TO CONTINUE TO DO WHAT
HE'S BEEN DOING.
WE CAN COUNT ON IT IN 2020.
>> THIS IS THE UNDERCURRENT OF
THIS ENTIRE TRIP.
MANY WITH AUTHORITARIAN FIGURES,
BASICALLY WHEN CAN I NOD TO
PUTIN, WAKE AND A NOD TO MBS.
>> IT'S ALSO THE UNDERCURRENT OF
HIS ENTIRE PRESIDENCY.
HE LIKES STRONGMEN.
I'M APPALLED.
>> TO THE PRESIDENT BASICALLY
INVITE PUTIN TO INTERFERE IN
2020?
>> THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T REALIZE
THAT WHEN HE DOES THAT, IT SENDS
A TERRIBLE MESSAGE TO THE WORLD
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS WEAK.
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS WEAK.
>> Sean: WHAT DO THEY WANT?
TO THEY WANT THE PRESIDENT TO
GET INTO A DUEL OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN, GO MMA RIGHT
THERE IN FRONT OF THEM?
DO THEY WANT HIM TO START A
PUBLIC BRAWL AT THE G20?
DO THEY HONESTLY THINK THE
PRESIDENT COULD SAY SOMETHING IN
FRONT OF THE PRESS AT A PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT WOULD STOP THE
HOSTILE ACTIONS OF RUSSIA?
WELL, NO, AND REALITY, THE MEDIA
JUST WANTS TO BLAME THE
PRESIDENT FOR EVERYTHING.
NO PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TOUGHER IN
MODERN DAY ON RUSSIA IN RECENT
YEARS THAN DONALD TRUMP.
SAME WITH IRAN.
NO ONE HAS BEEN TOUGHER WITH
IRAN.
ON THE SANCTIONS STILL REMAIN IN
NORTH KOREA.
LOOK AT THE REACTION OF THE
PRESIDENT FOURTH OF JULY SALUTE
TO AMERICA.
AND BY THE WAY, THE HYSTERIA,
THE PHONY MORAL OUTRAGE.
IT WAS A PATRIOTIC PARADE THAT
CELEBRATED THE MILITARY, THE
SAME MILITARY THAT DEFEATED
COMMUNISM, FASCISM, NOT CSM, AND
IMPERIAL JAPAN COME BOTH BUT
THEY WERE CRITICIZING HIM EVEN
BEFORE THE EVENT TOOK PLACE.
THEY KNEW WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT THEY WERE WRONG.
WATCH THE PREDICTIONS.
>> WHAT IS THE MESSAGE
DONALD TRUMP WAS TRYING TO SEND
BY ROLLING THINGS DOWN
CONSTITUTION AVENUE?
IT WAS THAT MESSAGE TO?
'S INTO THE RESISTANCE IN THIS
COUNTRY?
"I GOT TANKS, I HAVE THIS
MILITARY ARMADA."
THE MESSAGES OF THREAT.
IT'S ALWAYS A THREAT WHEN YOU
ROLL OUT YOUR MILITARY PARTED
BUT IT'S TO WHOM IS THE THREAT?
I SUSPECT AS A THREAT TO HIS
FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> I'M JUST PERSONALLY OUTRAGED
BY THE PRESIDENT HIJACKING THE
FOURTH OF JULY.
>> THE JUXTAPOSITION OF THOSE
IMAGES COME UP THOSE CHILDREN IN
CAGES, AND HERE IS DONALD TRUMP,
THERE ARE THOSE THINGS FLYING
OVERHEAD, AND THE TANKS.
IS THAT REALLY THE MESSAGE WE
WANT TO SEND ABOUT AMERICA?
>> THIS IS NOT WHAT WE NORMALLY
THINK AS A DEMOCRATIC DISPLAY OF
OUR VALUES BUT RATHER THE VALUES
OF POWER, OF MY TO MAKING RIGHT,
OF DICTATORSHIPS.
>> THIS DID NOT JUST OBNOXIOUS,
IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY AN AMERICAN.
>> Sean: OKAY, THE SAME
FREEDOMS THAT ARE PROTECTED
EVERY DAY.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE A
NONPARTISAN, PATRIOTIC SPEECH.
THE GREAT HISTORY, THEY EVEN
MADE FUN OF THAT BRAIDED HONORED
OUR COUNTRY, AND HIGHLIGHTED THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
SERVE THIS COUNTRY IN UNIFORM TO
PROTECT OUR LIBERTIES AND
FREEDOMS.
THE MEDIA PAINTED A MUCH MORE
SINISTER PICTURE, PREDICTABLY,
FROM THE FOURTH OF JULY
CELEBRATION, THE BRIEF MEETING
WITH KIM JONG UN, THE APPRAISER
WAS VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THE PRESS IN THIS COUNTRY IS SO
CORRUPT, THEY WILL USE ANY AND
EVERYTHING TO SMEAR THIS
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS WHO THEY NOW ARE.
THEY USE THE SAME TACTIC WITH,
OH, THE JEFFREY EPSTEIN CASE.
YOU KNOW, THE WELL-CONNECTED,
LUBE WHILE THE FINANCIER
RECENTLY
INDICTED ON SEX TRAFFICKING
CHARGES.
NOW HE ONCE HAD TIES TOO MANY
POLITICIANS AND CELEBRITIES.
INCLUDING BIG TIES TO THAT GUY,
BILL CLINTON.
HE TOOK VERY MANY TRIPS ON
EPSTEIN'S PRIVATE PLANE.
WE CALLED IT,
"THE NEW YORK POST" DUBBED IT,
THE "LOLITA EXPRESS."
GOING TO DENIED WRONGDOING BUT
WE COVERED THE STORY EXTENSIVELY
WELL BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION.
THE REST OF THE MEDIA AS USUAL
DID NOT ASK ANY QUESTIONS.
THEY WANTED TO HELP HILLARY AT
ALL COSTS.
ONLY NOW THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
INTERESTED BECAUSE EPSTEIN ONCE
HAD TIES TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
THROUGH SOCIAL EVENTS AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
NOW WHAT THE MEDIA IS NOT
TELLING YOU TONIGHT IS THAT
TRUMP SEVERED ALL TIES WITH
EPSTEIN.
LOOK AT THE COURT DOCUMENTS.
HE BANNED HIM FROM MAR-A-LAGO
YEARS AGO.
TRUMP WAS REPORTEDLY COOPERATIVE
IN THE 2008 CASE AGAINST
EPSTEIN.
NOW THAT MEDIA WILL USE THE
SICK, DISGUSTING CRIMES OF THIS
GUY TO ATTACK THE PRESIDENT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE GUY THAT IS
REALLY GOOD FRIENDS WITH
BILL CLINTON.
IT'S BEYOND SHAMEFUL, WRONG,
SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW BETTER.
THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
RATINGS, BY THE WAY, HAVE
REACHED THE HIGHEST POINTS YET.
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
LOOK AT THE ECONOMY IS BOOMING.
NO ONE PREDICTED THE JOBS
CREATION IN THE MONTH OF JUNE
ALONE.
224,000 NEW JOBS WERE ADDED,
BRINGING THE UNEMPLOYMENT DOWN
TO A STORK 3.7%.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE MEDIA
SAYS, THE TRUMP AGENDA IS
WORKING.
RECORD LOW, THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969.